all right let's go back to the discord
lines and hear from some more folks you
can find the david pakman show discord
at davidpakman.com
slash discord of course why don't we
talk to
um oh you know what you know who's on uh
new grongler from california is here
crossover caller from the majority
report and
other shows that some may be aware with
uh aware of
new what is going on oh hello david
hello so i'm not gonna bring up
that thing you told me not to bring up
before you started recording
okay so let me begin by not bringing
that up
now right so i've like you know as
you've mentioned
i've been getting radicalized over at
friends of the set
the majority report with sam theater
and they have assessed that the friendly
language
of democratic party leadership like
biden and pelosi towards republicans
yup is a significant part of what let
republicans gain seats in the house
recently
saying things like we need republicans
republicans will come around
after trump is gone et cetera and you
know i've had enough i think it's time
for
the democratic party to start trash
talking these clowns
you see what i mean by radicalization
but anyways sure
let's not forget that the trump admin
didn't
want to do stimulus checks at first
calling them bailouts of
democrat run cities right so
i ask you know is it time or is it risky
because
i guess mansion would be even less
cooperative
i don't know that i understand the
question is the question about the
rhetoric towards republicans or the
discussions within democrats
uh no the rhetoric towards republicans
like should
democratic politicians start you know
kind of just
abandoning um
you know this kind of friendly attitude
towards bipartisanship
yeah okay i understand it okay so this
is a good question listen here's here's
my thought on this and i even talked
about this earlier in the week to
some extent i think it's good to say
you would rather get something done with
republicans than without them
i think that that's a great thing to say
why not right let's
if we can if we can do something with
republicans without compromising our
values let's do it with republicans
i think it's great to involve
republicans in the conversation when i
read that joe biden has had
this or that republican at the white
house and they talked about this and
they talked about
that's fantastic but you've got to know
when to cut it off and so now we have
reports for example that the
negotiations with biden and republicans
on the infrastructure bill
are now done because republicans you
know biden sliced a trillion dollars off
and republicans came up 150 billion it's
like come on guys
that that's not going to go anywhere so
you just cut it off
and uh the the problem for democrats is
twofold
number one now there's like a moderate
group of democrats and republicans
negotiating the infrastructure bill
i don't know that something that gets
negotiated by moderate democrats and
republicans
actually gets 60 votes in the senate i
think you end up if you're on the on the
democratic side
your only option will end up being
budget reconciliation and
that's if you can get 50 votes and then
it becomes a matter of can you convince
joe manchin can you convince
kirsten cinema so i don't have a problem
with the talk of bipartisanship i don't
have a problem with negotiations i don't
have a problem with involving
republicans
but at a certain point you have to cut
it off and you have to say we're doing
it our way and we're just going to do it
the problem is if you only have 49 votes
in the senate then you can't do it and
that's where joe manchin gets all of his
power from
yeah it's uh kind of bleak
it's bleak i'm not gonna lie but listen
we still have memes right we at least
have that
we we do that's true um i i should uh i
should get started on some of those too
i have some ideas
please please i think that that would
bring a nice uh positive energy to the
show
all right you know what the means i am
waiting for though is uh
when the elections get close and
the means last year of uh i don't know
something important and then it cuts off
to you saying
doesn't matter we need to get out and
vote everybody right
we're gonna get back to that we're gonna
get back to that all right thank you for
the call my friend
ah thank you all right there we go uh
noog wrangler there for the longest time
i was having trouble finding snacks that
are healthy but
actually taste great and fill me up and
satisfy
a craving and that's why it's great that
i stumbled upon
monk pack and we asked them to be one of
our sponsors
monk pack keto nut and seed bars are
delicious
snacks that have one gram of sugar or
less
only two to three grams of net carbs and
just 150 calories perfect for a
keto or low carb diet or anybody who
like me
just prefers to eat a low sugar diet i
love the monk pack
keto nut and seed bars because it's
really just a great balance of sweet and
salty
soft and chewy but with a nice crunch
from the nuts and seeds
flavors include caramel or caramel
you tell me sea salt sea salt dark
chocolate
and peanut butter dark chocolate that's
my favorite they'll give you all of your
money back
if you don't love it go to monkpack.com
the link is down below
and they'll give you 20 off any of their
products when you use coupon code pacman